all right summer's winding down and what
better way to say so long to the season
than with some great barbecue and that's
what they're doing at the wind where the
great end of summer barbecue celebration
is set to take place here to tell us
more about that is executive chef
kelly bianchi of win las vegas thanks
for being here first of all i'm so
excited to be here we are super thrilled
about this event it's going to be really
fun it's fun for the whole family which
is
something in las vegas that we
definitely need on holiday weekends so
we're going to obviously have a wide
variety of food that we brought here
today and that we're going to have the
day of the event
fun for the whole family carnival game
second year you've done this two minutes
second year yep we're going to have
carnival games we're going to have live
music so we have a live band coming in
an amazing barbecue what you're going to
say you know carnival games band blah
blah blah barbecue baby you've got some
brisket that looks phenomenal here we're
very very excited about all the entire
menu plan we have brisket we have some
beautiful baby back ribs
we have an awesome broccoli salad we got
our house made barbecue sauces baked
beans braised kale and the desserts are
going to be amazing so gosh
here and you are going to prepare
something for us as well what you got
going so obviously to compliment great
barbecue you need a nice crisp salad
right so end of summer we brought in the
best ingredients from summer today
so we have a beautiful little summer
chopped salad that we're going to put
together
with a red wine vinaigrette
so we've got some roasted sweet corn we
have diced persian cucumber some
heirloom cherry tomatoes
romaine iceberg we did a little crispy
quinoa which is great give it a little
texture
some sunflower seeds and scallions and
then we're going to be serving those in
these cute little jars um and so it'll
be it'll be great yeah
let's put it together so the event by
the way while you're preparing this uh
you said september 3rd is that correct
that is correct and to get tickets what
do people do so you're going to go to
winlasvegas.com
and there's a link there right on the
home page that you can connect to
and that's going to link you over to the
ticket page
and it's just as easy as that you can
bring the whole family down
it's going to be a great time it's in
our brand new pavilion space which is
absolutely beautiful it's right on the
golf course it's stunning
beautiful view of the 18th hole just a
really nice place to spend the evening
and tickets are roughly 100 bucks is
that right yes yes right around right
around there and i believe there's a
another ticket price for children as
well okay what does that get is it you
like just eat whatever you want you eat
whatever you want and it's we're going
to be open for i believe about four
hours for the vip ticketed price you
also get two cocktails included wow so
that's going to be that's an important
part of staying cold chilled and relaxed
during the summer
especially at a barbecue
salad looks amazing and fresh what are
some of your favorites of the barbecues
that you guys serve um well i think
we've got them all here so brisket you
can't go wrong right well you can if
it's done actually you're absolutely
right yes but we are not we are we are
really excited about our brisket
it's going to be phenomenal wood-fired
smoke
we're going to have the smoker out there
on saturday it's going to be amazing and
then baby back ribs are one of my
favorites
i love baked beans i'm from kansas city
so i love it so you know barbecue i i've
eaten a lot of barbecue in my day yeah
so okay listen i think the salad looks
amazing but you know what i want to
taste that brisket over there i'm gonna
yeah find a way to try it out get a
piece of that
i mean
the salad wonderful not
underselling that for a second
uh but let me just oh my goodness you
don't even need a knife for this i can
already tell this is good yeah it's
gonna be amazing we're gonna have a
great time we're excited to be able to
invite families down to the wind um and
just have a really you know celebrate
the end of the season
oh my gosh how do we do
marry me right okay
mercedes this is amazing back to you
thanks kendall well school is in